après parlant du voile alors voila tu
tournes par arrive alors on peut dire
que voilà le avant le glacier des 102 ou
dans la photo la textualité gitan dans
la paf et encore il faut bien l'avouer
pour la haute et on l'a fait beaucoup
beaucoup au groenland
je pense qu on doit parfaire des choses
que la daf edwards alors la jet et 1000
points
mais ce choix sauf la 6 e place et d'un
second en bas la texture devant nous on
va en faire d'autres envers d'autres
regardent et à ta droite michel valet
car le colonel abdoullah renforcent la
logique observant en voie royale à plat
plat plat
quand tu fais des trucs comme ça
non maintenant regardez là même qui
compense la coquille ahmed en même temps
plus de dieu a du talent dit à la barre
du tournoi est assez pauvre en buts
mais voilà on arrive bien leur apprécié
d'avoir un très très beau glaçon moins
bien au temps glacé montagne comme ça
semble assez mal en moins bien que son
reflet
on est d'accord tu peux plus je pense
france ait trop de je regarde les bosses
et noir sur la glace je trouve choquant
le nom ans et plus pour une ombre qu au
soleil
vous constaterez pas de soleil l'air là
où trois à quatre mois
au milieu la voilà or nous laisse pas la
gauche at war ii lanta dedans
complètement voilà dans le détail de
laval à de la glace là c'est parce qu'on
bosse à 4,6 à peu de lancre les couler
et toi comme ça tourne c'est parce qu'on
bosse avala attentes autres ont la peur
hante et peut descendre pas l'histoire
scolaire pause
pas de corps noir et blanc rouge
on se bat
parce qu'on
la deûle entre toi et c'est non
refaire au second poteau
c'est bien
moi
regrette le père en large pourquoi les
côtes power 8 heures avoir des soins qui
les prend très beau toutefois c'est très
très très beau tout ça alors la fois
c'est république j'ai vu en enlevant ce
mélange de noir ça se boit l'on voit
plus
ben c'est en tout cas
pourquoi
à dire pour tous
qu'est ce que c'est bon ça [ __ ] passé
à tomber sa paire massa au japon temps
et on s'en va là ensemble
partir d'un puits que celles offertes
c'est que ça rigole
vos sens non parce que j'ai du mal à le
faire
blake
grand prince de bretagne la scie avec
deux mandats en pilant blanc comblement
comprends pas que des trucs dans la
terre là on atteint
la glace le soleil tout mélanger ce
colis la grève continue elle même qui
chantait savoir les coupeurs de p g
police est à part
quelque chose cela
on le roule à droite il est magnifique
percée 2
et peinture ça carrément
en fait
un vol prochain 70e baïkal
un talent brut pib elle pas parce que tu
as le le porte-voix pas le vendre et
c'est bon je devoir couper 1
pourquoi reste trois minutes
les canaris bon endroit pour qu'il s'en
aille à gaza
l'oeil comme un deuil je pense que je
disais que tu penses que je fais exprès
voilà la question
on fait un métier leur est dû
c'est bon
vous tenez de loin
après peut-être là
à chasser leurs fins
il aurait pas gauche je suis désolé je
côtoie